- hold on evictions during the pandemic  but that moratorium will expire next  week that means you will legally owe any  rent not paid during the entire shutdown  this starts on July 1st that's one week  from today many families say they are  now scrambling to figure out how to make  that payment and what their next steps  will be we spoke to an attorney named  Thomas felt he told us tenants and  landlords need to work together right  now to find a solution if you have a  good tenant whether it's a resident or  it's a business and they have been a  good tenant historically and no reason  why they shouldn't be going forward then  absolutely you should makes economic  sense you need to think long term not  the short term in these last couple  months so if a landlord does decide to  evict one of their tenants fell says  they should be prepared for that spot to  not be filled immediately due to the  current economic climate